foreign
do something and I'm like oh okay I
would say in the manual that I got
of things to not say when you're married
you need to fix yourself was was one of
those lines
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloti show cool cats and kittens I
think I'm just going through puberty did
my voice just correct I think it did hey
that's all right
it's all right
um hey I'm glad that you're here and
that you are walked alongside us we have
a packed house out here not really
there's like four people but it's good
to see y'all too everybody good to see
you
um if you want to be on the show
greatest mental health and marriage
podcast ever ever give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291-1844-693-3291 or go to
John deloney.com ask
also
again we're trying to put a little bit
of light out into the world the show's
just got really dark all of a sudden and
by all of a sudden I mean since we
started it and so we're trying to put
some joy into the world so if you've had
some success stories things that go have
just gone amazing you've listened to the
show and you and your husband talk
differently to each other or you are a
little bit little bit better parent or
forget me you found somebody else that I
recommended and they've been a big help
to you whatever it is we want to share
some success stories out there so go to
John deloney.com ask and just put
success story in the byline there and we
would love to have you on the show to
talk about it or if you don't want to be
on show I can just read it and that'd be
fantastic and
hit the Subscribe button for God's sake
hit the button just kidding I don't all
right all right let's go to Molly let's
go to Molly in San Diego what's up Molly
hi John what are you doing I'm just like
um well I'm talking to you for one made
my day because I'm freaking out because
I didn't think my question would be
answered oh don't freak out I'm not very
good at this
trust me we're good you're good you're
good what's up
um so yeah basically my question is how
do I kind of fix my marriage
I know we're just you're just talking
about that but like basically the way
you set that up was like I think you're
gonna ask my question it's not that big
a deal I thought you were gonna ask me
like I don't know what what I what shoes
I think are cool you're like how do I
fix my marriage all right help me out a
little bit uh dig in a little bit
Yeah so basically
um
I've been married for three years and
with my husband for about eight almost
nine and he's just frustrated and
you know we've been having a lot of
fights lately
and he's like I'm just sick and tired of
you
so like you gotta fix yourself I don't
know how but you know get therapy do
something and I'm like oh okay I would
say in the in the manual that I got
of things to not say when you're married
you need to fix yourself was was one of
those those lines
um okay so he's not he's on the phone
with us and so all I can talk to is you
and so I don't want this call to be all
about him
tell me what's happening in your mirror
tell me what's happened in your marriage
the last three years
um so we're
we were pregnant and then now I have a
one-year-old baby girl so I know he's
stressed out but then he also kind of
made a side business during the pandemic
and he's also working a full-time job
it's just expensive to live in San Diego
but no question about it no question
about it but what does that have to do
with them sick of you you need to fix
yourself
so basically our fights are very
repetitive and when we got together
um I gave him a list of what I want so
what I wanted was okay so did you just
hand him the Spice Girl lyrics like you
like you gave him a list of what I want
it's incredible
for a husband I'm being real I'm like
I'm not getting anything younger you're
not getting any younger so like is this
for real
and my list was basically like okay
you know my goal and this is you know I
was dreaming with him and I would say it
doesn't sound like you were dreaming
with him it sounds like you were telling
him what he was going to do to be a part
of your dream
okay I know I know I know but this is
gonna play I can already tell it's gonna
play this is gonna play into
what I think your next steps are gonna
be but I want you to own that this was
less about us dreaming about a future
together and this was more about you
handed him a list of the things that you
want and by the way this relationship
I'm already gonna tag it with a ton of
pressure because I'm dating to marry I'm
renting to own right I am like I'm in
this thing
I will only go out with you with an end
in mind not to get to know you not just
to find out who you are not to be you
are a means to a thing I'm gonna do
is that fair
yeah that's pretty fair and then you
handed him the list
just you should frame this list and put
it you hit him the list okay and so what
was on this list
so basically
um I just wanted like a partner that was
I guess beside me when I say beside me
is this
I wanted us to be like a power couple
constantly on our A-game
um you know constantly getting better
improving ourselves and then also
staying in communication of like what we
wanted
and just
you know
how I always see you know successful
marriages I just wanted to be one of
those and that's what I told them and I
was like you know I want us to keep
dating I want us to constantly you know
be a positive couple for also like our
kids
because you know both of her parents are
divorced and we didn't want that so we
went to marriage counseling and our
passion has blessed us and
well we did two sessions of marriage
counseling because of communication is
one of my biggest areas so that's also
why he's also frustrated yeah you're not
good at it I can tell you right now
you're not good at it that's okay
there's the third things in my marriage
that I'm not good at and I've been doing
this for more than two decades right but
it sounds like you gave him a job
description
of this is the way things were going to
be and if you go back and I want you to
listen to the things you said by the way
you have to I'm going to ask you to do
something and you have to promise me
you'll do it you promise
yeah do not read the YouTube comments on
this okay cool
oh yeah I know I know okay good social
media okay so listen I believe with all
my heart that you are coming at this
with the best of intentions
you live through hell as a kid
he did too yeah and you have come to a
place where that will not happen again
and the way it won't happen again is I'm
gonna control every variable moving
forward
correct
yeah yeah and so I bet you're a joy
first time new mom too right incredible
and so I'm gonna control every variable
because I will not get hurt again
and so you end up hiring a husband
you don't roll over and look at somebody
in the eye and say I love you so much
and I'm giving you access to my soul and
that means you can hurt me worse than I
was hurt as a kid and I'm asking you not
to do that let's build something
together
that goes against every fiber of your
being for good measure because that
happened to you when you were a kid
because all kids are is there just
walking exposed vulnerable little
creatures and so they absorb their
parents hatred for one another and their
fights and their frustration and all the
drama
and so it makes perfect sense
so I'm not I'm I'm sitting here with you
I totally get it
but I'm hearing the other side of this
which is I don't want to work here
anymore
yeah that's what I'm getting to and if I
look at what just what you're describing
it sounds like you have a husband that
is working his butt off to create a
vision to to help create the vision for
your life
and if you go back and listen to the way
you laid it out
want to be a power couple a couple
that's always doing this that's always
there's nothing about a couple who
abides in one another
I rest
I can I can anchor off the side of this
thing because I'm so anchored into you
and vice versa
and instead of saying here's a list of
what I want my demand list here's what I
need and those are asking somebody for
their needs is an invitation
asking someone to do what you want
it's a totally different proposition you
know what I'm saying
yeah I hear you my boss tells me what I
will do
my wife asked me hey here's what I need
we'd be a part of this
and one of those is exhausting you've
worked for bosses like that it's
exhausting I wanted it like this I want
it like this this is who our company
we're gonna do this we're gonna make
this much money it's just like all right
dude all right cool
I need a break
yeah that sounds about right does that
make sense
yeah he's just frustrated because I
didn't meet that expectation that I said
no it's not always frustrated it's
frustrated because he loves you and you
won't let him in
oh okay he's frustrated because as soon
as he starts moving close you push his
buttons so hard
and you will nag and complain him to
death right Am I Wrong tell me if I'm
wrong
but just fight I don't negative
surprisingly I don't nag okay so you
might not nag but that it could be worse
because nagging is just little bitty
drops
right like I'm just I'm just sprinkling
every minute of every day that'll kill
somebody but so will just letting it all
build up until you blast him with a fire
hose the water amount is the same
that's true oh okay okay listen to me
carefully the issues that y'all are
dealing with are not the problem okay
the issues are setting off automated
responses that have been guiding your
life for years
you will not get the marriage you want
by controlling every variable you will
get the marriage you want by completely
letting go and say I love you till the
end of time will you love me back
and sitting down together and saying hey
let's build this thing that we want
because he might not want to be a power
couple he might just want to love his
wife like crazy and go for walks in the
neighborhood
he may not have a vested interest in
being the couple that everyone looks to
you may just want to love the crap out
of his wife and his kids
which of course over time makes you the
couple that people look up to
oh
see that you see what I'm saying
yeah and I understand listen to me what
I'm asking you to do is going to be the
most terrifying thing you've ever done
it's gonna be scary than having a kid
because you already had that mapped out
and planned out and blogged out and you
listen all the podcasts and you got the
books you were ready to rock and roll
uh
actually no I just let whatever happened
what I don't believe that first I don't
listen
the issues will keep coming up and by
the way if you leave this relationship
or he leaves this relationship these are
going to show up in your next
relationship are going to show up in the
one after that
uh-huh
because you have you've married your
unfinished business
you're gonna have to let go your body's
still trying to ask what was so bad
about you that Mom and Dad split up
and you're going to show the world how
freaking perfect you are
and you're not he's not either and
that's what makes it the whole thing
incredible
I see okay
you're so ridiculous oh got it ding
ding all right
I'm just like you know set Whoever has
the highest standard go with that yeah
that's it's stupid it's dumb
dumb
it's like marriage is not a high jump
competition
so dumb that's terrible advice
and if one of your pastors wants to call
me I'll tell them that to their terrible
advice she was at the higher standard
and you meet that standard and then you
raise that standard dude you are s
that's you're setting your marriage up
for competition
yeah and it's a one-lost proposition and
that is not how successful marriages
work
no successful marriages open their eyes
every morning and they look at that
weird nose hair and those weird
breathing noises and God what happened
to your eyebrow like all that
and say I love you because I choose to
and I'm gonna be about helping you meet
your needs today
that's how it works
I would love for you to take your
husband out and say the what I've been
trying to accomplish isn't working
and I'm sorry
and by the way I know he's not perfect
he's just not on the phone with me okay
hopefully he pitches in on his part okay
but you gotta be willing to go forward
if you can't qualify and be like and you
know you've been you can't do that don't
do that because he's got then he's got
to fight you he's got his Wall's got to
come back up
yeah
so I'm sorry
and tell him I want you to take my wants
list and I want to throw that thing away
and start over
what world do we want to create together
what do you want this to feel like what
do we want this to look like what do we
want this our experiences to be
how can I best love you
and not here's what I want but here's
how you can best love me but let him go
first
I think I I I I I I think your marriage
is going to be great
you and him stop trying to compete for
whatever some gold star
and be about loving each other
and be about a shared vision of What Not
the next 40 years are going to look like
you don't know what's coming in 40 years
let's get through six months
what do you want the next six months to
feel like to look like how can we do
that
let's start there and let's do this
again in six months let's do this again
after that
let's keep building and rebuilding and
building and rebuilding and building and
rebuilding let's do it together
that my friend is marriage we'll be
right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode sponsor better help
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is life
changing stuff but I'll be honest it's
not easy these are new skills that we
all have to learn and therapy is a great
place to practice these new skills and
that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to Tejas
let's go to talk to Jacob in San Antonio
what's up Jacob
not much how you doing John I'm doing
dope on a rope man what's up how are you
oh not much could be a little better I
kind of over indulged on Sour Patch Kids
and chocolate chip cookies last night
listen homie listen listen
same team man same team
hey let's hey okay totally aside I I
turned in my final book draft at 1am on
Friday morning it was due at midnight I
was an hour late
listen I got on a scale
it was not dude I had a trash bag behind
me I looked at it after I hit send it is
the most disturbing trash it's filled
with
candy wrappers it's absurd and so listen
I'm detoxing right now not in one of
those like it got me a special lemon
ginger tea none of that bull crap but
like I'm working hard now man to clean
my soul up so my heart is with you
brother Jacob you feel like that swollen
like Just Stay Puft Marshmallow like you
just feel all brawl right yes yeah dude
I know it but they're so good they're so
good okay what's up okay so on the 20th
y'all did a factor your friends about
alcohol
and I've been kind of struggling with
that and I am 15 days now yay dude way
to go
so and it's not a long time but it feels
like it to me no no you don't get to do
that on the show
15 days man is that a win
yeah it is that's a win we're gonna
celebrate it we're not gonna minimize it
we're not going to compare it to
somebody else's 10-year token we're
gonna say hell yeah 15 days way to go
man good for you I appreciate that okay
so I'm just wondering where to go now I
find myself
kind of struggling I mean I've been
working out pretty much every day just
I'm trying to find things to kill time
no no no no no no
Jacob your life is not something to kill
okay okay
time I was just I was just listening to
a conversation uh with Peter Tia and and
recolias it was a beautiful conversation
and I think Rick I think it was Rick
that brought up if we had to every
morning deposit money for the day's time
we would spend it very very differently
our time
but we just throw it away we waste it we
sit on the toilet for five hours we play
stupid video games we just like we just
wasted
I don't want you to look at your life as
something like just to kill until it's
all over
you see what I'm saying yeah I do and I
also that's in that's in like you're in
the phase where it's still minute by
minute right
it is yeah and it's like trying to find
doing things but not drinking like we
did at game night and usually we were
all drinking when we do a game night now
I'm stoning what's sitting there and I'm
like man this sucks yeah dude
I feel better the next day because I
didn't wake up in a haze of course you
did yeah and you remembered everything
but also
okay there's a several things how long
you been drinking for
well I'm 43 since I was probably
junior senior in high school I would
guess a long time
um take me back six months ago how much
were you drinking
oh I could easily finish an 18 pack a
weekend plus Bourbon and stuff during
the week uh quite a bit okay quite a bit
what made you want to quit drinking
I just got I've
nothing was working uh everything was
chaotic
and I kept thinking I would just drink
to kill the chaos and it wasn't that uh
it wasn't working so I'm like well
that's not working and I'm killing
myself doing it there you go let's let's
do something else okay so what you just
said is really profound and so I'm gonna
say it back to you in a little bit
different way okay
you have lived a life since you were a
junior a senior in high school
that you were hiding from
you're trying to cover up cover it up
with a tarp
and the thing about alcohol is it works
really well for that
it allows you to get to the next day and
the next day and the next day and allows
you to thumb your way I mean just kind
of stumble through a marriage and allows
you to stumble through work until you
find your next job and but it works
until it kills you right until you look
up and everybody's gone
and so the the path before you hey quit
drinking right and you've done that you
were on that are you going to AAA you
are you going to meetings no no this is
just okay you have to me by myself you
have to don't do that okay you cannot I
I I I can't
you cannot do this by yourself
okay
and I know you want to you can't
okay okay quick pop quiz can you do this
by yourself
no no okay you said it not me okay you
can't do it by yourself all right so
that's number one
number two once you get Pat out of the
fog and you're in you're two weeks in
it's about another two weeks or so
you'll start to be able to see the world
a little bit more clearly okay and
here's where I think it gets really
existential hard you're going through
the physical hard right now so people
need the doctor's help to get off right
it's tough quitting
where it gets really tough is when you
realize I don't like any of the men
sitting around this game table with me
I don't like how they treat their wives
I don't like the way they they look at
the world they're just trying to kill
their lives too
in the nerd world we call it long tail
suicide
I'm not pulling a trigger I'm just
slowly ticking off the days on a
calendar until this whole thing just
rides off into the sunset
and what you're gonna find When You're
Sober is
you got a lot of things to be grateful
for
you're 43 so you're about halfway done
right statistically speaking yeah and
also how did I get here I don't like my
job I gotta find new people to hang out
with I'm gonna have to right so you have
to rebuild some really important
Scaffolding in your life and that's hard
you can't do that by yourself I wish you
could man I wish there was a way to do
it by yourself if I could figure that
out I'd be a trillionaire you can't you
can't CEOs whose lives fall apart and
implode can't do it by themselves multi
bajillionaires can't do it by themselves
drunks on the side of the road can't do
it by themselves nobody can Tower we're
made we are tribal animals man
and so what you're gonna have to do is
stop don't just go to another thing that
puts a tarp over your life that just
maybe kills you a little bit slower than
the alcohol was starting to kill you
let's let's get with a group of people
so we can pull the tarp completely off
our life and look at what we got
and then let's start building the life
that we want
Insurance see what I'm saying in that
that's like that sounds crazy doesn't it
yeah you've never even considered that
no
so dude this is your Independence Day at
43 years of age
and it's both liberating and freeing and
freedom is also terrifying
yeah yeah it is you know it's scary huh
yeah I just kind of going into the
unknown
yeah and that's the part they didn't
tell us when we were kids is when you
get to be adults it's all unknown
every adult I know is just making it up
as we go
yeah
and if you've got real smart kids
they'll call you on it
kids are way too smart yeah exactly
um
how many kids you got
three 20 25 20 and 14.
are they still within your area they're
still in San Antonio area yeah yeah my
my two daughters live with me with a 14
and 20 year old 20 year olds in college
but living at home in the my son my son
he lives out and with his wife in New
Mexico okay I would love to see you plan
an intentional meeting with your son
y'all meet in Lubbock and
I want you to sit down and look them at
the eye in the eye and say I
had this and this and this happened when
I was a kid
and I've spent the last 25 years running
from it
and because I was a running you as a
little boy were always wondering where
daddy was even when I was sitting right
next to you on the couch and I'm sorry
all that changes today
and I want you to put your hands on his
25 year old face and he's going freak
out
I want you to look him in the eye and
say I love you and I'm going to say it
every day for the rest of my life
whether you hear it or not
okay
and I want you to be honest with him and
tell him that you're in a group you're
getting sober and that you are
damn well determined to live the back
half of your life with a reckless
abandon where you're going to love and
be connected with people and you're
going to go on adventures because I'm
freaking Jacob from San Antonio dude I
can't
how does that sound
scary you did yes and this is the pep
rally speech right this is like the 80s
Montage like where the music's playing
and you're like oh yeah and then you can
actually go to the gym you're like this
sucks like Sylvester Stallone made it
looks so great it's not it's awful it's
cold right yeah
um so the path forward is hard man it's
hard that's why again you can't do it by
yourself
but at some point if you go to if you go
to like a 12-step group or some group
you're gonna have to go make amends
you're gonna have to go look people in
the eye that you realize I did my best
I did my best stuff I provided for them
I made sure they had food I made sure
they had shoes and that's all really
important that's that's Noble that's
part of the deal
but I withheld me
I might do that anymore and what you're
gonna find in that process my brother is
a ton of healing
a ton of healing because my I promise
you you miss him too
and those two precious daughters you
miss them like crazy too
and you they live in your house and you
miss them you know what I mean
yeah
what do you do for a living
uh project manager for construction
do you love it or do you hate it
[Music]
I couldn't care less if you were this
pretty principal owner and CEO and you
made 10 million dollars a year what do
you want to do
I don't know I don't know it's something
I've started to ask myself good hey I've
just been doing this for 20 years 21
years and hey you're going to find
you've just quote unquote been doing a
lot of things for 20 or 20 years 25
years
right and you never stop to ask yourself
what am I doing here
and the fact that man
you're a good dad aren't you
yeah oh yeah feel good about that oh
yeah are you a good husband
yes better than I was well hopefully we
all are right yeah hopefully we've been
married 20 21 years now we've been
married so yeah I'm right there with you
and hopefully in 30 when I crossed the
30-year threshold I can look back and be
like man I'm way better than I was at
the 20-year Mark right yeah um
even my wife's seen she's made a comment
she's noticed the difference in the last
two weeks okay take her out and do the
exact same thing that I told you do with
your son
okay because my guess is for a long time
you felt completely and totally alone in
a crowded room
oh oh it's all the time and my guess is
you've probably shared a bed with a
woman for 20 years that you love and
that you know loves you but you feel
completely and totally alone
yeah yeah we yeah
yeah a lot of the times yes
let's stop that
I say this with all due respect at some
point that's a choice to hide
I agree I agree and you're gonna have to
practice not hiding because not hiding
is freaking terrifying well I know my
wife's forever telling me use your words
[Laughter]
when our wives talk to us like we're
Toddlers and they're accurate yes yeah
she's a school teacher too so even even
better my wife was also trust me oh my
gosh
um
the idea that you are Unshackled now you
should feel terrified by that and I
don't want that to freak you out and
anytime you feel scared about the
unknown scared about vulnerability
scared about driving to meet with your
son and hold him by his face and tell
them that you love him and hug him so
hard that his ribs hurt
your body will be terrified that whole
way
so I'm telling you that to Norm it it's
it's to be expected it's the same as
when you go in for knee surgery they say
hey the next six months after it's gonna
be hard and you go okay I'm gonna do it
anyway because it's right does that make
sense
yeah most people when they're getting
sober they experience this pain this
relational pain this boredom you're
talking about
and they think that they are somehow bro
it's confirming that they were broken
and they always have been and it's easy
to go back to the thing that made them
feel feel okay which is alcohol in your
case
if you don't replace it with
a destination here's where we're going
with purpose you're just going to move
your addiction right you're going to
find yourself down some pornography
Rabbit Hole or you're gonna be working
180 hours a week under the guise of
quote unquote they need me and really
it's just you hiding from your family
and from people who know you and love
you okay the goal here is is to create a
life
create a a an ability to look in the
mirror and say I'm worth not hiding
because I'm freaking Jacob from San
Antonio and I'm loved and I love other
people
that's that's what healing looks like
cool
yeah
sounds sounds good you're so full of
crap it sounds awful
it sounds awful yes it does it sounds
awful but
ah I know it's the right thing to do
it's just okay so before the day's over
before today is over
okay you're gonna find a group
you don't have to tell anybody you're
going but you're gonna find a group
doesn't have to be an AAA group or some
big but you gotta find a group it could
be there's any number of groups San
Antonio guarantee it
and there's also quiet I wouldn't say
secret but there's Quiet Ones for
executives or people who are high
profile or whatever like
find a group second thing is put a date
on the calendar with your wife you don't
have to go tonight because it's going to
take a minute for you to gear it up you
probably should write her a letter that
you can read to her
okay okay
third is get on the calendar with your
son
put on calendar don't do not bail on it
is that cool
that's cool
I I it's been one of my great life
honors to talk to you man you're a brave
strong man it's awesome
and I'll be with you as any any way
you'll invite me in I'm here dude call
me anytime you want shoot me emails if
you want um and I'll walk alongside you
as you as you completely transform your
life
I want you to hang on the phone I'm
gonna send you a copy of own your past
change your future the book and I'm
gonna send you some conversation cards
for your daughters and for you and your
wife
because we're gonna practice just
hanging out it's a thing we haven't done
a long time or ever we're gonna practice
just being in Commerce and Community
with one another just hanging out just
doing hangout things
and maybe it'll give you a little bit of
uh reprieve from looking around the room
of your board game buddies and being
like Oh my gosh how did I end up here
yeah I can't wait to see what happens
next bro we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right let's go to Mel in San
Francisco California what's up Mel
hi thank you for having me of course
thank you for calling what are you doing
so I struggled with an eating disorder
in secret for a majority of my teen
years
um I'm currently 20 and I'm fully
recovered but I noticed that I'm still
generally unhappy and I've started to to
wonder if recovering from the eating
disorder was only treating the symptom
and not the root problem uh when I look
back on my younger years
I feel like I never really knew how to
relax I was always in my head yeah yeah
so I I guess my overall question is what
steps do I need to take to start feeling
genuinely happy
[Music]
home life is hard huh
um I feel like
for some reason I
I think the the problem was socially I
always felt like nobody really
understood me even back in like
Elementary School
common I don't want to throw shade at
your home life okay
yeah a common
root of what you just said is people
don't get me
generally start starts at home
and that can look everywhere from don't
do that like nobody wants I don't have
time to look at your drawings or why are
you dressed like that or quit dancing
and singing so loud it can be any number
of
small quiet things that are trying to
keep peace in an otherwise peaceful nice
facade home
and what you learn at a young age is I
need to
control me I need to shut this machine
down
and that's a really tall order for a kid
and then often that stuff leaks out of
school and then people at school call
you weirdo or call you whatever kid and
suddenly
whoa
now I'm not telling you that's your
story I'm telling you if I was a betting
man I would put my money there I might
be wrong I may lose that bet
now you're 20. what does recovery look
like now
oh yeah
habits and now I feel like I don't
resort to those things when I'm feeling
down
but
emotionally I feel like I'm not in that
much of a better place
how did you who worked with you to get
to this place
yeah when I was 18 I ended up
with a therapist and a dietitian for
about a year
and then I moved out of the house and
from that point
um I was able to eat more regularly and
move on from those bad habits
so before we get into the what comes
next
I want you to be able to Exhale for a
second
so take a big big inhale and hold it
like as big as you deep as you can
and hold it for the count of one
two three then let it out when I want
you to pull your shoulders down as far
as they'll go okay
you've done a really extraordinary thing
a powerful extraordinary unbelievable
thing
and so someone who's just meeting you
for the first time
I need you to hear me say I can feel the
strength and resilience on you
okay thank you
and
I think that chasing happiness the
quote-unquote pursuit of happiness is a
dreadful journey to go on
and here's what I mean by that
if I'm chasing happy that I'm chasing
feeling good
and if I'm chasing feeling good
then ultimately I start chasing not
feeling bad and if I start chasing not
feeling bad I start chasing not being
uncomfortable
and there is no growth without
discomfort
there's no achieving a purpose or
achieving goals or having deep wonderful
meaningful relationships without
discomfort
and so one of the great cultural lies
we've been told is that
not feeling uncomfortable is the goal
not feeling
um sad is the goal not feeling
frustrated or mad or angry is the goal
and we duct tape over everything and we
professionalize everything so we don't
have to see death and we don't have to
see discomfort and we don't even have to
have hard conversations with our friends
we just have them with our therapist
everything's become professionalized and
all of a sudden we have found ourselves
in these comfortable chairs in the
middle of a life that's going nowhere
and our bodies are shutting down on us
so what I want to challenge you is to
not make happy the benchmark
I want to challenge you that pers
purpose is your benchmark where do you
want to go where do you want to be what
what lights you up inside
how do you the the Old Frederick beekner
what's the great need in the world that
brings you Joy that that crystallizes
your purpose that you can cross I mean
you just have that that perfect XY axis
match
what is it what lights you up
um I've been writing since I was about
seven years old yeah and currently I'm
writing fiction novels and I feel like
I've always been
an overachiever and I've always known
what I've wanted to do with my life and
I've had that sense of purpose
but
I and I guess I'm going in that
direction
I don't know if anything's changed in
terms of how I feel about writing as my
career if it if it doesn't make me as
excited as it used to I think it still
does
but I do feel like I'm
I'm pursuing what I want to pursue but
maybe I want to pull it apart let's pull
it apart why do you love running okay
okay why do you love writing
um
it's kind of hard to know I I started
when I was really young and for some
reason I haven't stopped do you love it
because you get to create worlds and
then inhabit them do you love it because
you like the reaction people give you
when they read your work do you like the
um like the discipline of having to get
up and write every day what are the
things that bring you Joy about it
um I enjoy the therapeutic nature of it
just also having a routine
um like waking up having my coffee
writing
um and I do also enjoy other people
reading my work and writing reviews or
telling me they enjoyed it
um I do think that if I was not sharing
my work I probably wouldn't be writing
so that's the very big thing for me I
love that
so let me tell you this so at 16 I think
uh maybe I was 15. I got a job at the
local Burger King
right in my neighborhood and I ended up
working there all the way through High
School even into the first my first year
of college I came back over the summer
and worked there
and I learned in short order
that it takes about 15 seconds to make
somebody's day or to ruin their day
and people would come in with that
standing in the in the in the that long
lunch rush line and they'd have that
Dead Eye there was no cell phones back
then so it was just this numbed out
staring off into space look
and by just quietly saying hey how's it
going how's your day
there was this conscious Snapback to
reality right and oh there goes rabbit
right and so they would they would snap
back to reality and they look you in the
eye and be like oh man it's great
today's good or it's not so great and
then I could say I'm so glad it's going
well or tell me about it and this is all
while I'm just ass taking your number
two combo with cheese but no onions
right it's very quick and here's what I
learned
that that made me feel alive
and then I went to college and
ultimately ended up studying education
and I worked with young people for years
until I started I went and studied
counseling and then I started getting
into mental health and now I'm a
freaking YouTuber Mel
like I've got a podcast now
I've had a bunch of different jobs from
Chief student affairs officer at a
billion dollar University to Burger King
Frontline guy but if I pull a thread
across all of those I wanted people to
feel a little better after interacting
with me than when they got there I
wanted people to have a little more
peace a little more joy in their life
and a little more optimism going into
the next their next phase
and so I tell you that to tell you this
you love the routine of writing and you
also love sharing your work with
somebody else
I don't want you to feel the pressure of
that means I have to be a professional
writer for the rest of my life I am one
of those too I write for a living also
that's a hard life it's a hard life
and the place I work at Ramsey we have
our own publishing house I didn't even
have to go get a deal it's a hard just
just writing and deadlines and edits and
sub-edits I was making edits on the way
in on the phone today with an editor
it's hard life my wife is an author it's
a hard life
and
is there some places where you can bring
your talents to help a business that's
struggling to communicate their story
about how they can help somebody's life
into the marketplace is there a place
where you can become a teacher and teach
other kids how to get in touch with
those feelings inside of them is there a
place where you can
Share work with other people or share
stories with people there's a whole line
of counseling called narrative therapy
where you right so I'm telling you not
to tell you this your purpose will be
less in the action and more how you make
other people feel
and more how you are lit up from the
inside out
and all of this is going to have
discomfort along the way
and so I think the real challenge moving
forward is how does Mill make peace with
discomfort
and how does Mel
create structure and I know you can
create structure right a few people can
create structure like you can can
override their innate systems to get a
certain outcome you can do that you're a
gangster at that
how can you become not militant that's
the wrong word but how can you become
very disciplined in here are the things
that I know make me feel better here are
the things that I know bring me joy here
are the things I'm going to do them even
when I don't feel like it
and my my guess is over time your body
begins to shift its default setting
there's a great line and I think it's by
it's by Adler are you one of those old
psychologists um kind of the foundation
Founding Fathers of psychology and it
was this
I thought I could make my clients well
by taking away their anxiety and
depression
and what I found is I just made them
empty
I had to take help them take away their
anxiety and depression but then I had to
fill that back with joy and optimism and
laughter and purpose
and so you've done the incredible thing
of stopping the hard stuff
you're no longer
um you're no longer hurting yourself
anymore which is amazing it's so hard to
do and if you've if people have never
experienced that it is truly
mind-boggling that you've pulled this
off in the short of time now amazing
the next question is how do I take that
empty emptiness and fill it up with good
stuff along the way
you see like in in I hope you hear my
voice like I am smiling about it like
this is optimism this is a thing to be
really excited about exploring not
something that should shut us down
it's the adventure of a lifetime does
that make sense
yeah it does that sound like woo-woo
nonsense
it should because it kind of is
I just don't know how I I find those
things that make me happy
I feel I've
I feel like I have a lot of hobbies but
they don't
excite me that much
or they don't excite me as much as they
used to
that's fantastic they served a role in
your life
maybe your hobby is learning new hobbies
maybe your hobby is for six months at a
time spending time with a group of
wackadoo cooking students and then a
group of wackadoo yoga kids and then a
group of
hey I don't know essential oil salesman
don't don't be one of those or like
whatever somebody who breeds doodle dogs
I don't know what like it it it may be x
and y and z
the thing is if you enter into those
looking for ways that they will complete
you they never will
you're complete
you're good and worth being loved and
you're all of your weirdness and all of
your affictions to all of it it's all
it's your whole
it's now going to seek those things not
that are going to fill you up and quote
unquote make you happy it's going to be
the things that bring you deep
satisfaction and into relationship with
other people
and so I tell you if you used to do
things that really lit you up and now
they're like man cool give those a ride
man sell your bicycle and go get a
guitar or sell your guitar and go get a
what like whatever the thing is
another thing I'll tell you is this
I would recommend with all of my heart
above all other things
to go get a new counselor
and to say
I went through this time in my life I
really really struggled from distorted
eating and from some pretty
um over exercise exercise addiction and
I'm now in a place where I'm not doing
that anymore
and now I need to practice what comes
next and I've never had to do this
before this is a new territory for me
will you help me practice what's next
you may have some depression in there
you may have your body May respond with
some anxiousness it's just your body
trying to take care of you as you head
into uncharted waters and having a
professional counselor that walks
alongside you is really important during
those times
[Music]
you're worth being loved and you have
strap yourself to the Mast dude while
the storms raged and the storms passed
and now there's calm water and now you
can untie yourself from the Mast and say
all right where are we gonna go next
[Music]
get somebody to walk with you
I it's it's an honor to have gotten to
spend some time with you Bill you're
incredible we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back um as we wrap up
today's show this is
um I don't know
y'all don't know this and I'm kind of
blowing her cover on this um Kelly won a
poetry contest in college she was really
proud of it and ultimately she sold this
poem to this group of unknown British
women
at the time they were called the sugar
girls and they ultimately changed their
name to the Spice Girls and so they
wrote this amazing song turns out they
didn't write it Kelly did and so this is
this is from the depths of her poetic
Soul when Kelly reaches deep this is
what she comes up with the song's called
wannabe
yo I'll tell you what I want what I
really really want
so tell me what you want what you really
really want I'll tell you what I want
what I really really want
so tell me what you want what you really
really want I wanna I wanna
I wanna I wanna really really really
wanna zig-azag
if that doesn't move your soul call a
therapist now
Kelly going deep Kelly going deep we'll
see you soon
[Music]